community is uh a means to an end
it's not an end many times oh i want to
build a community no
let's see if community is a tool to
build that connection
sometimes by the way the community can
be the tool to build the product
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford building a community around
your brand is not trivial
in fact it's quite hard and we have mike
silberg here with us
talking about his own experience the
challenges of it and why it's so crucial
meet mike silberg founding partner at
iscl
since 2002 mike has worked with
companies such as red bull as a brand
manager
at kpmg and the management consulting
team and at wework
as a community manager but also smb's
ngos in government
in 2017 he founded the iscl summit
international startup community leader
summit the event that it brought
together
over 500 startup community professionals
from over 50 countries
the event spawned as agency iscl also
known as the iscl network
a decentralized community agency working
with companies and organizations around
the world
mike silberg welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you today
i'm great michael thanks for having me
thank you for joining me we're going to
talk about communities we're going to
talk about brands we're going to talk
about marketing we're going to talk
about your own journey
and how you formulated your own thesis
behind what it means for
for companies to interact properly with
the world around them
and you've founded also organizations
like the iscl
bringing together a lot of startups and
and a lot of people in the ecosystem to
learn together so
mike take me back a little bit walk me
through your journey and the key
milestones
reaching all the way to where you are
today with your today's understanding
of how companies should integrate with
communities
so um i think it all starts and it
usually starts from a younger age
and when i started all kinds of small
businesses
and somebody asked me and i was cleaning
my father's car and somebody came and
said
can you clean my car also i was 10 years
old and i started a whole business and
the whole street was like
my turf i started cleaning cars so it
starts with being a bit entrepreneurial
and not being scared
and taking reactions and always thinking
big and thinking about growth and
thinking what you can do even more and
how to be better in what you do
so and maybe the second milestones when
i was 17 18
again growth mindset i knew it was going
to draft to the army and said i want to
go to the best unit i can and i went for
a pre-army training for a whole year
which for many people sounds cool here
training a whole year for a mandatory
three four five years
yeah a whole year two three four times a
week
and i lived in a small town i had to
take i hit i need to every training i
needed to eat hitchhike and take a 30
minute bus
for every one an hour and a half
training
it would be like three hour four hour
journey every time for
for a workout for a mindset session and
stuff like that
and i really loved it was one of the
most um
molding uh experiences of my life many
of my values and things that happened to
me are thanks
actually i think to my pre-army training
which was focused on
building me and building my mindset and
building my ability
in order to be accepted into special
forces which was i was lucky enough to
be accepted and finish a course in
and still do my my um
reserve service at but the main thing
that what happened that happened when we
think about my career afterwards
and the pre-army training business is
the worst business in the world you know
why
why a hundred percent turn in customers
100 churning customers you know all the
customers
leave they go nobody comes back
okay and even if they would it would be
three four years later
so the pre-army training is the worst
business you have one time that you use
the customer and you will never
universities you can come back to an mba
anything else usually you can think even
if you do it you can do something you
can upsell
pre-army training that's it you did the
army you don't need the pre-army train
anymore
so and and it was really hard and what
he was the first i think in israel in
his field
he's already 36 years around that was
like the 16th
class uh 16th year and i said listen
you know we're getting to the end of the
year and and
i s how how is it gonna grow next year
and i knew how it grows you know
word of mouth and people knew about and
people who were looking for it
the internet started and that old it was
the beginning of
of this century but it was mostly people
from word of mouth and people knew about
it and it started with like five ten
people
and in our group there were about 80 or
100.
so wow that was the beginning and said
why wait so
long until the end of the year and hope
the word of mouth will work and and yes
he advertised and everything but to be
advertised in the last minute
he said listen we're all bit very
passionate about
what you're giving us and about the
journey you're taking us in
let's tell that journey and i said that
started
before and what i did i think i took a
group of four or five
we weren't alumni yet but we were people
that already went through
the big part of the training and were
already accepted to the to the units we
wanted to be accepted for
and i did a panel and i took that panel
and i sold it you know
free and i went to all the high schools
in the region to 30 different high
schools and listen
do you want me to bring four youngsters
that were par that
were part of army pre-training and were
accepted to special forces pilots chorus
naval naval academy
to come and tell them about how it is to
do a year free army training
and without of course advertising or
anything but of course all the stories
are from
the place i came from and i did that
in 30 schools and you know we were all
happy and we were like panelists it was
a meet-up the year 2001 2002
and a seven-year-old sells this thing to
all people
and when the year started usually in the
beginning of the year he has
more people and you have a churn during
the year that people that don't stick to
the pre-army training because it costs
money and it's
and you need to come you need to commit
but he started my year with about 250
270 people
then follow usually he would grow 10
every year
the following year when we did that
campaign okay
which was that that was the like putting
it into people's mind
and what i did i took all the alumni and
they did it every year but i managed it
like an army operation
i took all the alumni i created like a
pre uh
pre-recruiting session about how we
would go to
to the schools and everything and and
recruit them the next generation
and it worked and in the first training
of the year
it was for 550 people
more than double he had like 80 people
wow we were there 270 if you want to
compare
and the next year was 550 jumping almost
four years later
i finished my army training and i
finished my army training and the first
thing i want to do is do my sats my
my uh you know to exams that we do in
israel in order to accept
to university i knew i had to get a very
high score 725
which is a 20 a story of itself i went
to the
to the counseling office and asked how
much do i need to get except
automatically for um economics and
accounting
and they told me 725 and i said okay i'm
gonna get
that score and i said what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna find a
security job working at nights that i
don't watch tv
and don't be distracted and in those
times i'm gonna study
eight hours a day while getting paid and
suddenly after i do all that
the guy calls me and he knows i finished
the army services hey mike you remember
what we did
of course says now i'm going to open 10
centers he only had one then
we're going to jump from one to 10
branches and you're going to leave this
and i was 22
and i said okay he said listen what's
your price i said the price per hour
that was double the minimum wage for me
it was
huge so great you write your hours and
you
recruit like you did last time take all
the alumni
and try to work with them to bring the
next generation and open this 10
branches
and that's what we did we opened 10
branches and that became my
summer job because he does it only once
a year okay
for six years and every year of course
we were better and better and better
um and and that was like part of my
beginning of the career i didn't call it
then a community i didn't understand
about
it's what we call today as a more
professional person works with
communities we call it
leading without authority i wasn't their
boss
they didn't get paid it was all about me
tapping
into their inherent
um um let's call it
um um their appreciation of what they
got
their inherent like of the brand their
connection to the brand their
understanding
right and their gratefulness that was
the word i was looking for they've been
grateful for what they achieved
and that's what i say today brands have
to have a multi-level
and people know it but they don't really
execute it
they need to have a multi-level brand
and connection
with their customers potential customers
and the people around them because
that's the multi-level connection
and the multi-level connection says i
don't just you give me money and i give
you a service or product
i give you much more than that the
problem is by the way that many brands
or many people that start a business
think about the things around
more than the core value and that's a
mistake community
is a means to an end it's not an end
many times oh i want to build a
community no let's see if community
is a tool to build that connection
sometimes by the way the community can
be
the tool to build the product okay
but many many times people confuse the
means to an end
to the goal itself and and not every
time
it's it's working many times i try out
customers and that's why by the way my
business model i do
three stages and say let's start a stage
of strategy i called um
initial analysis let's do a sprint of
strategy it's not the final strategy
it's just you know
what we would do and see if it works
well and see if the if
community strategy is a good thing for
you the mistake companies do
say okay we're going to do community i
see everybody's doing community let's
open a community
let's start hiring three months process
hiring somebody
and then say okay you have background in
community you built a community
now build our community strategy get
everybody on board make everybody work
for free
work for you know from from the team
that's you know ready
overloaded and it's the last thing in
the top of their head to start helping
the community manager the new guy in the
office
and and you know the customers that
right now why should i help you
and and and that's the thing the process
of building community is a process for
people running marathons
it's a thing of you know you need to tap
things slow and that's like exactly my
story
you put the story you start building it
you cultivate
those people and then you see it grow
more and more
i think that you know the way that
you're you're you're talking about your
background you're starting off with
with you know jumping into a community
that you don't even know that it's a
community
and you just understand that there is a
huge power in this idea of ambassadors
and this idea of people that are
that are way beyond a transactional
relationship with the brand it's it's
really a personal relationship
personal advocation you know it's it's
sort of taking this idea of word of
mouth but
it's but extracting it to its really
core essence
which is all about trust it's all about
you know relationship building it's all
about
friendship and and i think that that you
know bring that now to the
to the real world and companies and
you're what i'm hearing you say is that
right now in 2021 we see almost every
company trying to create a community
but it might it might not be for the
right reasons and if you don't do it
authentically
and if you just do it as a means to an
end then it's not a real community it
doesn't have the same
network effect as what you had in that
army pre-training course
which sounds to me like a perfect case
study for what it means to build a
strong community right
um totally and and i think you touched a
point that's very confusing to most of
the people because it is
because we used to having okay one goal
and
when i built the community strategy i
created some kind of graph
that i said how meaningful is it for the
company how meaningful is it for
the community and trying to and the size
of the
of the impact a three-dimensional um
graph and that's the thing because we
need to find where the most
high level value was is for both sides
so it's not just having a means for that
because yes community is
should be a means for an end for the end
of the company
but you have to understand that it
should be a means to an
end also for the customers it doesn't
matter it's not always customers it can
be much more than that
and you have to trickle down and show
and as you said there's a mythology we
built which we call the community peaks
you can't jump to everest you can't
become a community
there's a path and all kinds of levels
you have to go
the first thing in the community peaks
model is is creating
a shared identity okay we call it plm
people like me the feeling
that you know people that we have shared
values that we know
we want to work together this i can do a
whole lecture about just the plm effect
and the idea that we feel that people
are similar but it leads us to the next
part
about trust and then also we found
there's a great book called trust agents
and talked about how you build trust
online and offline and there's a whole
um formula about how to create trust
that we use a lot
and we and it's not that it's we know
how to use the formula with every
community with every community we see
what part of the formula
has a big bigger factor and then that's
the factor is the fact that we use
and the factor that we choose in
building trust is what's available
how do we want to move trust what's what
affects the people in
the target audience we affect and then
we start moving what we call
sharing which sharing is what we say is
giving without feeling you lost anything
okay when you sh
and then we talked about reciprocity
reciprocity is a longer term
value of saying listen i love helping
you or like being a mentor because i
know
i was helped before and that's the cycle
of the spiral of creating
more value and more value and more value
and companies who build communities
become addicted one of the companies
that help build the community is kpmg
accounting firm very gray very dull and
what is community there's no
you think about accountants you don't
think about of a huge heart you don't
think about colors you don't think about
an emotional connection
and the story there is that one of the
market
yes and one of the marketing team i i'm
a
alumni of kpmg and i'm going to give a
few pointers about the connected my
steve jobs connecting the docs
about that story 20 years ago was only
the beginning
okay at kpmg we were asked to
build a strategy to build a startup
ecosystem or economic
uh um high value ecosystem for bear
sheva you know
today everybody knows about bear
chevrolet cyber city but that was
something me and my team
in the management consulting team at
kpmg roads
and then today the prime minister says
it and everybody says it and it became a
reality
it was written when the cyber park in
bercheva was
a bunch of sand that's it
and the the something from the marketing
team knew me
and was following me and my blogs and
writing about community
said listen i'm right now on maternity
leave and i want to build a community
and i told them that i'm only coming
back from the maternity leave if they
let me
uh part-time work on building a
community long story short she built an
alumni community
the effect of the alumni community of
kpmg
bring more traffic bring more work you
know recommending
new employees there's so many levels of
values created
suddenly they created also and it became
a full-time job and she created the
student community the people studying
accounting to find the best talent
so it's a talent acquisition community
and suddenly
people the employees so they create an
employee community which is
employee committee is very interesting
because you can't do an employee
committee that's exactly like the
company so they found
a sub-community called the lecturers
within kpmg people
which are opinion leaders are really
lectures in universities
and then you create something that's
strong and they're more connected than
they become the advocates of kpmg
as part of kpmg so there's so many
stories happening within but that's like
me at kpmg in 2011 until 2013
and jumping back in 2018 when they
reached out for me to help them
with was that strategy so
while i was a student even before i was
at
i was it was a competition red bull you
remember red bull
of course of course they used to have
drinks in israel today you barely find
red bull
but red world used to have 94 percent of
the israeli market
it's the whole thing how they lost the
market but it used to be very big
huge and if you remember in 2009 and 10
was all these crazy events that read
what we do and they still do around the
world
fluke tag and softbox and if you think
about these events what's unique about
those events of that brand
and other events of other brands okay
even if you take up things like the tel
aviv marathon which is sponsored by
samsung
which is kind of cool because the
community because they're helping them
create a marathon but
i don't feel any connection to samsung
okay i don't do anything i come and i
run and i train for myself and i do
something alone and they leave
when you think about softbox a fluke bag
if you remember
fluke used to you you should you needed
to build an airplane
as a team and fly off a bridge and see
how far you get
into like the pond in tel aviv and
softbox was in jerusalem you had to
create this
softbox group and you had to grow down
now think about
the experience that connects you in
order to build a community you need to
do an experience
that's really transforming that create
and build first of all the plm
we all together have built something
even though we're all unique
we're all different in plm we have huge
diversity
but we still have something very clear
in common we all worked a few months
invested money time in um
ingenuity into building something and
with all the people that were teams and
fluke tech and software were connected
and there's something stronger to
connect the brand around
and those events people still remember
remember even the decade next
and me as a student brand manager at red
bull
red bull said you have zero money you
have a few girls with cars
and as much red bull you want to give
for events as you can
and my job was to create events with the
student community
okay in the southern part of israel with
all the universities and colleges in the
region
based on them and almost with zero
budget
i created a huge brand awareness of red
bull
during my student year which was amazing
i had a part-time job that paid really
well and all i did was
get free red bulls and create really
cool parties
and that's you know utilizing and that's
the power of community mike it sounds
like a
that's a job it's a it's like a dream
job and that's it a bit
so and and nobody calls it a community
but all that things of
harnessing the people around you and the
and the resources around us
that are there the passion around us
that is there
the people that have already you know
the need the
the the common needs the common um
desires the common
you know uh interests that's the people
you need to find
cultivate create but it but it's a
marathon as i said before
and so that's a bit of a few that
there's a few parts i know we're a 20
minute leader session so i'm going to
stop now
and if you have a few questions or if
you want me to continue a few points on
the journey we can continue in soon
mike i think we have to do a few more
episodes to try and cover
the breadth of what it is we're talking
about here we didn't even get to some of
the main things that i've written down
that i
that i thought of but i'm so glad we
didn't because i'm
these stories are exactly the stories
that i'm looking for in the show so
thank you
thank you very much for taking the time
to share that and and i just loved it
and
i i'm personally taking away so many
insights from this i have
three last questions that that i want to
ask and i'll ask the two of them first
first one who is one of your role models
and
what is your favorite subject in school
k-12
great so um role models
so i have a lot of role models and i'm
gonna say only a few because what i
understood
i always felt i'm not good enough i'm
very very critical about myself
and what i always did is and today i use
a lot of annie do
do that and i said what am i lacking um
i was always very enthusiastic and it
was a problem because kids sometimes
if you're too enthusiastic it's like
whoa you're you're weird like
be cool and i found when i was uh
in one of my jobs i was still at this
issue that i would too eager you know
what right as an employee i would write
like very long emails
i was like and you know and some people
around you don't feel it and i found
something
in my work at one of the vps and you
know that was very cool
he looked like the pink panther like he
had this smooth
very chill there and i said and and i
got close to him his name is eres it
doesn't it doesn't say anything but for
me role models
weren't the great people um that you
think about
it's the people i could connect the
people i would rub
off on and then really learn from
so if i think of on a large scale by the
way
it's i'm gonna be very very obvious
elon musk okay and um
the one what i like to think about that
is it's not about the money
you know it's about the adventure if you
think what i take from elon musk
it's about hard working understanding
it's not about you
you have to work hard the second by the
way has six
kids you know he doesn't forfeit his
family he cares about his family by the
way it's no
i saw a video about him he takes his
kids every morning to school
so two things that's very important
first of all
and that's i think is how you need to
think also about your business and
building communities it's not about the
money it's about
journey it's about you know where you
want to go and once you have
such strong convictions and things you
know
and such such big challenges you know
all the rest is peanuts
and all the other challenges along the
way don't matter because you have an
end goal that you want to go through and
he put all his money after he got all
the money from paypal
in his three new ventures that are
supposed to change the world and that's
where i think companies should go
and think about how they can also change
the world and also understand the values
of hard working
and on the other hand being with your
family and having some kind of balance
and regarding my my my school so i
i was always good with math and
accounting
and all that kind of stuff i loved the
challenge thing but it was actually
also totally big in on history and
when i was in high school i wanted to
major in so i majored in
physics um and in economics
and i wanted to do economics wasn't the
full major so you had to do it was
something i wanted to do with history
said no at the same time as physics so
you have to go with sociology
and that was my luck that i studied by
accident
sociology which was super important and
super connected to economics
so economics and accounting was
something i was always very big in
so since i was eight my father said i
would read
the the the financial reports from
globes
and read the stocks like i was eight
nine and started investing a very young
age and started to understand it and i
love the numbers and going up in france
and i loved economics and when i was
older i heard uma
daniel talks about economics and he was
asked to ex
to explain economics in one word and he
said incentives
and economics is exactly what creates
and connects
psychology psychology people
understanding people which what i loved
and i didn't understand that's history
history is understanding people it's
understanding human behavior
it's stories about people and the other
side of equations economics
and creating that and that's what we try
to do we call it community engineering
to understand it to tap into what are
the different
formulas and structures of human
behavior human needs
and try to put them into kind of an
equation even though it's organic in
changes
one of the brilliant things about
history and you all know how he speaks
about lot we could never predict history
because
it's like the chaos theory a small move
of the butterfly in one side of the
earth creates a tornado
in the other side and that's why all
this together creates completely
let's build on that and psychology
i love it and mike very quickly three
words that you would choose to describe
yourself
uh what are those three words
powerful and grateful
i love it mike thank you so so much for
coming in the show thank you for
for being so generous with your time i
know how busy you are thank you for
sharing with me
your insights all the way from your
childhood from from understanding you
know hands-on practically what is what
is a community and what is the power of
relationships and trust
and then extrapolating that more to
bigger brands and companies today and
how they're working
we have a few more episodes to do
together on the other endeavors that you
have
but until then thank you very very much
thank you michael it was a pleasure
being on your show